I'm very hungry I saved myself for this
[Music]
today we are gonna try
take a cookie go I am really picky about
chocolates I don't like any just like
normal chocolate oh you gotta have
Chinon yeah yeah KitKat and cookies oh I
mean I don't know how to do things but
I'm excited having a crappy day and
you're like I just really want some
chocolate to just have Mia I over
saturate myself with chocolate like you
over chocolate I try to pick up as you
don't let's do it yeah
break I don't think this can go that
wrong I'm it has to be good at to the
cookie dough it looks like a sports bar
okay get in the gym get chunky give me a
piece of that cake that is it chunky is
it pretty
oh you can break off a piece and share
with your pal I don't understand what
I'm eating I mean I keep biting it's
clearly too good I taste the extra sugar
for sure if you want to pull on dessert
this is better than a regular cake that
this is like you've given up a little
bit on my like you're like girl [ __ ]
that diet or flippin boyfriend just
broke up with you after you found out he
cheated on you yeah I'll eat the whole
[ __ ] do you think you're having a seven
bar oh if I wanted cookie dough I would
just need cookie dough now just try and
bring flavors together in here one
minute break into an ice creams press
releases the class and then Megan's is
gonna cook up great it's a great dessert
I like it thumbs up maybe a little more
cuz you gotta taste it feel like you
expect too much from candy bars maybe I
do